et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien voilà je joue aux échecs contre
l'ordinateur avant et alors tu gagnes
j'espère on ne gagne pas j'étais 3e au
championnat du monde minime quand
j'avais 12 ans j'avais j'ai arrêté de
jouer parce que je jouais tout le temps
jour et nuit
mes parents m'ont interdit depuis je
n'ai plus jamais rejoué et puis
maintenant je me suis remis contre
l'ordinateur kasparov le plus fort et il
est très énervant c'est en général est
épouvantable comment on peut jouer ce qu
ils gagnent à tous les coups
j'ai gagné deux fois sur 100 parties et
puis en plus il se corrige
c'est ce qui est épouvantable c'était un
peu plus on le pousse à bout et ils
trouvent toujours une autre combinaison
il a environ 120 millions et 10 millions
de parties en tête vont soit alors là
d'ailleurs c'est à moi de jouer et je
vois les pièces comme les autres voyages
de tonner surtout par kent a vu ce que
polak a dit dans mon émission la semaine
bouygues qui il a parlé à mon médecin
voser pouliquen à l'hôtel dieu
alors s'il a besoin de vérifier les
choses bougent ça ça embête les gens qui
que ce soit un film parce qu'ils
voudraient voir parfait c'est je crois
que c'est un excès d'amour de la part de
polak jacasser à chatila
alors là je rope je peux jouer de tête
de quatre ils me répondent à 7,5 à vg
f3 de régime et f6 vous cac40 je veux
dire j'ai pas tellement besoin de voir
des indications très content de vous
connaître puisque c'est l'année des
c'est l'année des fils caché des
figurines
moi je dis n'est que bercoff la semaine
dernière il avait amené sa fille avec la
maintenance tu veux c'est un truc quoi
tout le monde mène sa fille cachée
je suis désolé de pas avoir caché les
miennes meilleur berger
j'ai alors une grande nouvelle
jean-frédéric j'ai non seulement elle
est inscrite
ouais mais j'aime à masina c'est-à-dire
l'honneur perdu de françois mitterrand
il sera 80 mille exemplaires
mardi prochain oui et alors quel effet
ça fait alors de devoir sa fille cachée
qui réapparaît comme ça je sais c'est
formidable c'est formidable on a mis du
temps avant de redécouvrir cette
apprivoiser mais maintenant si vous êtes
redevienne reviennent de temps ya trois
ans parce que finalement imagine très
belle phrase c'est pas moi qui était
reconnue c'est toi qui m'a reconnu ce
que je suis allé à lui en fait elle m'a
dit moment où il ya trois ans j'ai perdu
la vue elle est venue voir l'hôpital
elle m'a dit j'ai perdu un mari mais je
retrouve un impair n'ont pas je vais pas
couché avec elle mais c'est beau vous
préciser si alors vraiment vraiment
comme quoi comme quoi l'ine dans cette
veine et puisque tu es drôle quand j'en
doute pas que de moi quand j'avais dit
oui moi la grand-mère quand jean edern a
reconnu qu'on a été à l'amérique d'une
part là l'employé pensée convenez
reconnaître on était un couple vous
veniez reconnaître un enfant parce que
c'était inimaginable comme situation
puis toi tu faisais des jumeaux
ce père dit dans les couloirs paires et
impaires alors ce couloir libère ce jour
là était un impair puisque ça s'est pas
très bien passé le lendemain sur la main
il a fallu attendre quelques années et
alors fulgurances la raconte moi c'est
bien fabriqué en tous les cas ce que
j'aime en vue durant ces bons le sourire
mais des bretelles ou bizarre mais que
les souvenirs heureux rendre le présent
à firmin pas débité deux phrases des
femmes pour les coutumes et les femmes
et les hommes pour les lois et les
femmes les coutumes il faut toujours
scie la branche sur laquelle on est
perché ça permet de s'envoler
c'est ce que j'ai toujours fait c'est
notamment être mitterrand tm dont
j'étais très ami et qui a écrit dans nos
lucidité qui doit bien regretter dans sa
tombe que j'étais meilleur avec 90
sièges génération les autres voilà ça
par contre ne soit pas terrible je suis
très douée pour gagner de l'argent et
même pour faire le maquereau pense pas
une phrase qui mérite d'être imprime les
cas vous savez que je suis par contre
les prix c'est pour consoler les
mauvaises écrivain c'est mieux ça c'est
juste ça c'est juste
ouais et l'académie française va pas
bien en plus les élections actuelles
avec beyond beauty cette espèce de
courge blonde à ce qui est écrit en chat
a bien commencé quand cet argent petits
pas les trucs comme ça jamais à
l'académicien serait-il les dix ans
maintenant non oui elle a plus besoin de
moi j'ai besoin de ça c'est bien mais
theron était un arbre la preuve il n'a
pas arrêté de se planter
non je souffre d'overdose du réel c'est
bien ça mais là les les gens pensent
court donc il faut lancer des flèches et
moderne ça se lit facilement ses biens
fabriqués c'est bien mais en page ça
vaut cher comme ça vous 50/50 balle et
l'autre vont 89,3 l'autre 89 précipitée
et la malhaute faut se dépêcher mais
bien c'est qu'on n'a pas encore laissé
comme gugler béatrice apparent ne s'est
pas encore lu ce mazarine béatrice quoi
hein
alors toi tu vois béatrice je vais te
dire un truc quand même tu l'as pas ton
livre à la main ah bon je me disais
quand même
et oui c'est un show 6 o defrag un
saucisson que ce soit que je viens de
faire un choix c'est une chanson de
cette chanson desailly des joies que moi
qui suis estate de choix tu as je trouve
ça beau de choix que génial admirable ou
de la peine
[Musique]
c'est leur offrant mois qui vient de
grèce
déjà je m'appelle au reste des joueurs
tapent à bouffer l'os de joie elle
débarque à paris de vos oraux quel régal
au devant de prendre le métro de joie
quand on tournait pas déjà le fond ce
qu'on s'amuse au dub et leur faisait
toujours mes enfants ma foi
les jeunes sont de vilains grognon du
jeune quand il pleure ton coeur joie
j'essaie de les distraire les marches je
viens à tout d'un coup d'un soir mais
les autres aussi sont de joie toujours
dans le besoin de jouer ça ne peut pas
de chèvre
non non pas du tout bondy mois jean
edern on va on va chez on va passer chez
adam la wii s'alluma way you lie en quoi
pour que le livre de julien de rendre
internet au canada avec le numéro et
tout mais si c'est réglé donc ça y est
les personnes fera jamais dit ça y est
dis moi tu connais chez adam qui sait
c'est une boîte de partout jusque dans
le xviie là juste à côté a joué à pas de
tortue va plus non paris la fille et là
c'en est donc fini elle peut y aller si
elle veut bon on connaissait déjà dans
je suis un libéral
mais plutôt chez m voilà exactement une
sorte de fournir une fois des tur en
gros de chair fraîche va pas toujours
très fraîche sauvage probable non mais
c'est marrant j'aime pas les parts ou si
j'aime pas avoir d'autres hommes autour
de moi mais plusieurs femmes j'aime me
voilà sauf les portes vite et est ce que
dans les serveurs damman la mère de
béatrice tu l'a connue comment ça s'est
passé comment ça s'est passé très bien
la nuit le jour moins bien un jour ne
ressemble pas aux nuits étaient
épisodiques
le soir quand j'étais à sa jamais les
prêts j'avais plus de d'un genre
comprendre et va t'en as ticket de métro
d'autobus mais c'est elle que je tourne
téléphona j'appelais simplifie et puis
va d'abord via le terrain c'était là la
fille de béatrice beck 6 et la vitesse 1
germain des prés et toi ça les snober
quand même d'être avec la fille de
béatrice beck n'ont ils jamais fallait
monter c'était difficile parce qu'elle
est placée à côté de la porte de la
grand mère elle laissé la porte
entrouverte et il fallait pas faire trop
de bruit puisque un grand maire
entendait rejoint suis très bien au
clair de lune dans la cuisine c'est
exquis
voilà ce que j'attends d'un produit non
c'est bien ça non je ne sais pas je la
connais pas leur histoire parce que ya
jean edern ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils ne
dit pas est ce que je ne connais pas il
ya ce que ma mère dit est ce que dit le
départ donc pour moi c'est rare
finalement un enfant qu'il connaît pas
l'histoire
maintenant moi je connais pas l'islam et
en asie dont jésus vosges alors ce
serait moi non plus je n'étais jamais
été de raconter ses histoires enfin
franchement c'est le genre les enfants
n'ont pas le sabbat ce tout ça quand je
sais pas d'histoires intimes j'ai pas de
thé véritablement la ville de nuit
depuis donné comme toi pendant 30 ans
fait la nuit s'il fait le numéro sans
frais les trois questeurs là ce sera il
posté dans le mettre aux nouvelles
étaient captés france et l'europe peut
réprobatrice béatrice maui parce que
elle elle est aussi évidemment ces
écoutes mais vous allez vous organiser
je ne peux pas être à l'origine d'une
nouvelle
on y va loin ciao
[Musique]
oui
patientez
[Musique]
témoin
vous allez où deux ans chez les rois
mages en galilée et à bas risque comme
des reagan jours
turenne sépaq a marre des artistes
je suis de ces langues
sur la
tous un par jour
le percement où serez-vous allemand vous
savez monsieur me tord est mort c'était
mon ami et un type est fait par le
portage cia pour moi ça braille connaît
c'est à mon hôtel ils ont côtoyé me suis
dedans et je peux m'en informe et vous
ait été remis ses tablettes
shoot à ina musique on a plutôt rappelé
sony membres lui c'est sa photo avec moi
doivent être des cinésites c'est qu'on a
c'est d'après moi c'est un affront c'est
pas notre place car ce sont des calmants
ça peut paraître voyage de passage mais
qu'il ya tout à fait à ces patients là
il est radié maintenant trois ans radié
de ses fonctions que mon âge et
réal et noah pour une bonne soirée
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir comment tu verras ça
pas besoin ici c'est pas possible c'est
la deuxième fois que j'attends mon nom
c'est là chez pourquoi je viens parce
que j'ai lu dans libé que c'était la
situation mais est ce la grande nuit des
sourires et des services et oui on va
assister aux préparatifs avec plaisir et
ses cuirs vinyle et latex
bonsoir présente diamino la veine des
souvenirs puisque le travail pour moi
depuis quatre ans donc à l'electro swing
dans ce cas là et en plus elle est
soumise à plus que ça ah ouais ouais
enfin sauf vous inviterez chez vous
ouais
et puis vous l'offrez une petite soirée
vous verrez comment elle est soumise
après quelques coupes de champagne dans
tous les cas elle est très jolie
oui et elle met pas de culotte soir
c'est interdit alors est comment ça on
la prépare je vais te faire tu vas voir
les préparatifs pour l'instant bain tout
le monde se prépare c'est là c'est un
peu si tu veux branle-bas-de-combat
voilà il ya même des feux des jeunes des
êtres qui sont là et ils ont commencé
ils ont commencé comme tu vois bonsoir à
se préparer bon sens vous voulez dire
bonsoir attire il est gentil il n'a
jamais mordu personne et en plus on
feint soumise sauf les civils mais vous
verrez que c'est un gars sont vraiment
très gentils thierry c'est vrai ce pas
c'est vrai c'est vrai je voue beaucoup
vu que ma réputation en toi tu vois tu
as fait le navire arrivé les gens tu
vaux mieux que ce que tu t'estimes y
paraît mieux
alors je vous présente ma québécoise
parce qu'entre temps depuis la dernière
fois j'ai divorcé je me suis remarié par
la mariée est en plein divorce et moi
j'attends le nouveau marié
je vous présente tania la rivière lgbt
trois rivières il est beaucoup plus
jolie que céline dion et chante beaucoup
et bien bon à quelle heure ils arrivent
les gens
9h30 c'est arrivé un peu en avance et
qu'est ce que je voulais dire vous
attendiez à voir
oyonnax le restaurant c'est bien dit je
te présente bonne nouvelle serveuse unis
nous viens vous présenter
bon ça arrive première garde des sceaux
alors là nico alors l'écouter
moi vous savez je ne fais jamais
publicité j'ai horreur de diogène boîte
ça ouais mais thierry si un jour tu
viens mon dîner ici un soir c'est au
conseil des chefs chose cette finir par
la mousse au chocolat
dix nouveaux venus expliquer comment tu
prouves on lui serre la mousse au
chocolat
je vous la variété monsieur et j'aimais
un préservatif délicatement avec ma
bouche
oui je mets la mousse au chocolat sur le
sexe du monsieur
je partage avec la dame et suite à ça
j'ai eu quatre divorces pas ce que
j'appelle marié qui veulent se faire
faire des révélations par notre ami nino
[Musique]
non non soirée très rapidement
ce qu'il a fait son pipi mais plus ça va
peut constituer non non non pas du tout
c'est parce qu'elle habite eu de souci
avec mon mari et moi c'est une fille
sortis moi absolument épuisé sur place
soit parce que il est en train de manger
une pizza avec les enfants parce que je
suis professeur et j'ai rencontré de
l'école vous enseigner quoi habib le
[Musique]
gimas et bien oui c'est tout les deux à
fouler une cheville oncle la t'exciter
s'appelle comment jeanne à jade comme la
fille de mick jagger jeudi pour une
fille oui mon argent vous vous appelez
comment
[Musique]
en
non
[Musique]
je sais
talleyrand
toi
j'aime wasps en fuite
il s'agissait
[Musique]
m
soir où c'est vrai que cette jolie on
avait des métiers joli mais là
franchement aulas l'a dit amer oui ça je
m'attendais pas de ta mère te là oui on
peut rentrer chez moi chez moi à quoi
oui très bien alors c'est j'arrive
j'arrive je t'attends merci tu vas toi
quoi
oui j'en attends chez toi ici la fiq
habitat à l'étape avait agi avec sa mère
c'est un peu le problème
je voulais rentrer non c'est vrai tu
venais où je sais pas je croyais vous
avez besoin français non je sais pas où
tu feras musée de la dentelle très bien
s'est réjoui attend vraiment on m'avait
dit ça mais je suis encore plus séduit
qu'est ce que j'aurais cru alors
d'histoire antonioni comment ça s'est
passé
ça c'est ça s'est très bien passé
c'était je crois une chance formidable
pour moi d'être dans ce film de choisir
comment il a vu des photos de moi dans
le l italien et il avoue quoi ta
personne duc et voulait me rencontrer on
a passé une journée ensemble et on a
beau courir nous sommes beaucoup amusés
voilà et
même mois après ils m'appelaient pour me
dire que j'étais prise avec les fans qui
sera la réponse a fait perdre sa récente
des bras je crois et ta mère te
surveille à elle est venue me faire une
visite cette semaine à paris parce que
j'avais quand même j'ai eu déjà je
travaille d'une manière très forte et a
eu la promotion du film il ya eu les
défilés de haute couture comme il ya eu
des grèves pour un mois de décembre les
universités avaient été un peu en retard
alors bon je vais à l'école aussi
oui je suis arrivé c'était quoi je finis
ma licence de lettres modernes président
c'est bien tu parles vachement bien le
français
tu parles de quoi parle le français
l'espagnol par l'espagnol l'anglais a
quoi comme des faux culs avant quand
elle jalouse
non non c'est possible ouais quand tu
aimes voilà chez toi ici
oui et en tant que mec là ça fait 80
c'est hyper bien rangée vachement qui
nous attendait pas mais c'est notamment
là c'est vraiment dans l'intimité
j'avais jamais fait un interview chez
moi alors t'as rien à voir c'est pas un
truc à boire un truc à bouaye niches par
un truc espagnol as pas grave j'ai truc
maintenant les choses à voir deviennent
très international
je vais pas te parce que là franchement
de s'ouvrir vers d'autres n'ont jamais
ce que tu veux je pars à verre de vin au
verre de vin vous à quoi tu bois quoi
toi moi je voudrais un verre d'eau à du
bois de l'eau je voudrais voilà donc les
berges on peut on pouvait avoir un petit
verre de vin
j'ai cherché à défaut je cherche un trip
à aller ailleurs parce que j'ai pas du
même plein chez nous c'est pas du vin
blanc chez toi non au café à main très
bien on voit que faire au revoir madame
je re bon vous la ramène pas qu'elle
n'ait pas trouvé qui attend quand même
on va où est-ce qu'un bistrot trocadéro
tu crois à l'entretien des routes a pas
froid comme ça c'est sûr je veux pas
être responsable de ton groupe n'ont
jamais rien passé je suis à faire
maintenant les collections c'est fini
oui c'est fini terminé je m'en tire en
vacances non pas du tout je voudrais
bien mais je peux pas j'aurai des
examens en février je suis en train de
nous être dur d'être une fille parfois
on les entend c'est pas dur d'être une
vie parfaite s'est pas dit que ce
n'était pas inquiète pour toi ta mère on
peut pas bien que je vous écris mon avis
il était surpris puisque la mine
il n'ya pas d'acteurs ya pas de
mannequin c'est quoi ces gens là et ma
mère et éditeurs du monde et viola davis
et s est un peu étrange que j'étais ont
été touchés en février à la maison mais
maintenant ça va mais avant tout le
monde fini tu es vie je suis là depuis
sa famille
donc ça veut dire que dans ce quartier
quand tu veux boire un verre de vin
blanc
il faut marcher une demi-heure quoi mais
ce matin la tour eiffel en flash 50 m
c'est pas mal
j'ai cinquante moment je trouve qu est
le seizième sais pas c'est pas bon il
faut qu'à des ressources ou bats toi
mais tu n'as tu pas froid
bon je lui fais quoi tu bois quoi déjà
de l'ombre
[Musique]
normal c'est vraiment moi fait ça ce
soir bonsoir
aujourd'hui un bon soir à deux verres de
vin blanc de neuf escales et ouais
d'accord tu fais quoi ton jules alors
complètement et tu ne connais pas parce
que je sais pas ce que je suis parce que
tes espagnoles mais les gens ils savent
si je serais curieux je préfère c'est
son rôle d'acteur la rénover il voit là
je pense qu'à dépasser très bien d'être
avec en être en contact avec des gens
qui m'aiment et s'éloigne un peu de ton
travail c'est bien si en fait je vais te
dire à thuir c'était c'était pour savoir
si tu avais à jules en fait je m'en fous
de ce qu'il fait
comme beaucoup
c'est gentil parce qu'elle ne connaît
pas aujourd'hui sous les balles à
l'adorable si vous vous laissez votre
place à je ne sais pas
[Musique]
revoir harry
petit séjour d'un mois revoir paris
[Applaudissements]
je veux retrouver chez moi
ça va produire
aramits la foule des grands boulevards
elle voit inouïe d'aller ainsi oise à
prendre un taxi
qui va le longue lasserre
et me voici
non
au fond du bois de vincennes
roulant joyeux hervé maison de banlieue
où ma mère m'a tant les larmes aux yeux
le coeur content
mon dieu que tout le monde est gentil
mon dieu qu'elle se rient pas laver mon
dieu merci mon dieu merci d'être ici ce
soir mais pas à quatre ans de l'an 2000
voici venir le temps est sorti quatre
ans avant 2004 en avant une nouvelle
période mais nouvelle période riche
qu'on appellera les années folles les
années tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
gilbert legrand des français
aux anneaux
bonjour
à
[Musique]
une
va-t-on
haché
sa tombe
karachi
jean genre à terre
et
oh
ah ouais
ouais
bonjour et merci pour ces femmes et
sport hippique
halloween as c'est chérie chéri tu y ait
eu cgt chez toi je suis venu voir ça va
dis moi tu sors pas ce soir qu'est ce
que tu fais donc tu peux pas sortir
non parce y avait un truc chez à danser
c'est le premier c'est le premier jeudi
du mois quoi tu connais la dent c'est
sympa comme boîte
pas grave on ira une autre fois voilà ok
ce marché là on vient me faire chier à
oran le soir ça va m
dans le rhône on chante je suis avec b
de [ __ ] c'est le voilà je suis en
train je suis tranquille hausse
bon vous m'avez donné rancart aie aie
aie ça y est je n'ai fermer la lourde un
bon maire dallas tu sais tu sais tout
ces poutres apparentes elles
n'apparaissent pas quand arrive
n'importe qui elles disparaissent elles
sont attendus parce que ardisson est
apparue moi tu sais bien c'est un lieu
historique c'est ici c'était là qu'était
la rédaction de zone hara kiri arrête ça
lui est horrible c'est comme c'était là
donc oui c'était là que se réalise toute
la grande tout j'ai dit ah oui toujours
l'un des grands génies tout ça voilà
c'est avec toujours là quoi je peux
avoir un glaçon je sais où elle était là
chez adam c'est la soirée tu connais un
temps bref une boîte de tous c'était la
soirée le premier jeudi du mois c'est
sur les d soumis l'idée soumise c'est
quoi bah c'est des mecs alors par
exemple puis il ya des filles qui font
table des filles qui font du sport c'est
bien tant que ça suce c'est bien moi tu
sais
j'aime bien les led leur sexe leur truc
tu tout ça mais je pense que le trou du
cul ya la mer de boue la chatte il y
adeux l'ami de la carte blanche des
pertes et noir et tout ça mais la bouche
c'est bien fait d'accord nous tuent des
sorts alors très copines sont
sympathiques comme tout bages et en rade
me faire sucer tranquillou ce mois il ya
un truc moi qui m'a toujours fasciné
dans ta vie c'est l'indochine légaliste
et partira dossier j'avais dix dans
borat est parti parce qu'il n'existait
pas le club militaire aligne à l'époque
donc pour voyager avec que sur leur mère
il fallait faire la guerre ouais et
j'étais attiré par l'extrême orient et
tout et puis c'était ça a été bon quoi
ouais je suis tombé complètement
amoureux d'extrême en ayant honte est
arrivé quand tu arrives et c'était août
et essayons d'en laure la [ __ ] non
j'étais là haut dans le nord tonkin
j'étais vraiment à la frontière de chine
sait dans quelle arme jt dans la
fonderie de marine au départ et qu'après
je suis tombé dans les parachutistes
coloniaux enfin que c'est lui fabié de
quelle couleur h était habillée c'est la
base est celle ci comment j'étais vers
un billet en chaude pisse au nom non
j'étais habillé en parle l'horizon des
bleus raison c'était c'est à dire j'ai
normalement on n'aura pas dû me voir que
j'étends tucat boufflers voilà c'est
quand même temps je suis resté deux ans
et mais j'aime bien beau pays magnifique
tout ça peut-être eu des gens tu le fais
pas exprès ouais petit tient dans le
tardis lyall grant a refusé une
mitraillette avait à l'époque qu'on
avait quand même déjà des mitraillettes
1 et tu tirais comme ça quoi tu retires
se rendre en terre se régale tt
j'ai tu réponds mais oui j'aurais même
d'avoir été là bas non non non ça a été
c'était extraordinaire en plus parce que
les gars qui al'air la chine on était
vachement mal vue en france
je sais qu'on se faisait feu des pierres
sur la gueule et moi je suis méchant
raconte t il
ces deux ans et demi là bas sont
revenues -enfin et je vais raconter
l'anecdote c'est que quand je suis
rentré de france
je croyais que j'étais un héros et j'ai
débarqué sur le paquebot pasteur et
finalement le pasteur est arrivé au
petit matin nous allons nous a fait
tenir jusqu'à la nuit parce que on avait
peur des des émeutes des mecs de la cgt
avait gros compte communique pas les
grands comptes communiste de merde
syndical cgt donc qu'ils jettent des
pierres tout ça donc on est on de la
nuit nous est arrivé le matin et c'est
quel port marseille et jusqu'au soir de
la saison le bateau à la passe que vous
deviez sortir la nuit sinon elle vient
de travailler si on a traversé marseille
la nuit tu avais camions bâchés
je crois que jusqu'au camp sainte-marthe
tu vas pour ne pas qu'on se fasse
agresser mais j'ai toi tu devais passer
de deux ans et demi c'est ça tu étais
parvenu en france pour une deuxième
rallonge ses besoins et la bad battre et
quand est revenue en août à cacher oui
mais laquelle
c'est faux donc c'est bien et engagé
vente
je vais bien porter sa extrême orient tu
sais à l'époque on était tous stalinien
petit père des peuples tout ça et le
communisme
tu te rends compte et moi je voulais
contre tout ça avec mes 19 ans extrême
orient tu vois c'est casser la gueule
dans les bars quand tu sors tu es tout
seul et on sentait jamais tout seul dans
surtout on a fait nos
nos stages commandos dans la zone rouge
diddy qui sont devenus les playlists
aujourd'hui assez grand con c'est les
mêmes grands corps ah voilà tout le midi
senna match sans et gros con à jour ils
sont communistes
un jury sur le peniste mais heureusement
ils ont le pastis d'iwata eu envie de
faire l'algérie après un non j'ai
toujours été engagés pour la corée ah
ouais harry mois l'algérie pour moi
c'est trop près de la france tu vas
achètent un pays que j'aime pas
donc pour moi je veux aller loin à je te
jure c'est vrai je te jure que c'est
vrai après tu voulais repartir au combat
mais c'est les américains
et quand je me suis engagé volontaire
j'aurais pu m'engager
non je me suis engagé pour l'extrême
rigueur est d'accord j'étais amoureux
d'ex en mariant et quand je suis rentré
je sais ce que je fais dans lutter pour
la corée j'arrive le matin justement je
vais être américain ouais
j'étais bien habillé les amalgames et
manque de pot la guerre de corée side la
remise pas de pot l'armistice mahmoud
jeunes d'armes ici donc c'est pour ça
que je suis pas dans chorus à ça c'est
sûr que j'avais en plus extrême orient
et puis la corée c'était une étoile avec
un indien s'étaient vus sur le blouson
exonère le blouson exonère vous avez
jamais vu l'une aux honoraires c'est ici
tu sais en france on est vraiment des
cons ils ont jamais bien habillé l'art
militaire force est plus personnel quand
tu as vu arriver les [ __ ] en france
avec comme le tablier les branches en
france les bals tous à une rugueuse
tu vois arriver les américains blouson
à chaque attente c'est un bijou qui
arrivait jusque là c'était cintrée là
d'une beauté tu as raison ce que ce sont
des soldats français comment a été zappé
on avait presque des bad molletières des
galas du tissu créé on a perdu la guerre
bah ouais je sais ce que j'ai fait moi
des chemins de chine
là il y avait des tailleurs chinois je
leur disais voilà vous allez me faire ça
et ça et il m'avait fait pour moi des
tailleurs chinois mon blouson est un
annuaire alors la qualité que je leur
avais dit en soi n'est alors j'avais
rodgers et j'avais rangers s'étaient dit
c'était des grands de godasses comme
j'ai un petit peu encore maintenant elle
est arrivée jusqu'à la rue était belle
comme tout tu vois la ccd belles
chaussures de cuir de cette couleur là
là c'est jusque là avec le pantalon ces
quelques années un stick
[ __ ] et tata qui descendait dans les
bordels de salon comment s'est elle est
bourrée de saigon c'était c'était beau
le rêve quoi c'est irracontable tu vas
loin c'est à dire ouais
tu vois par exemple je reviens à
repartir en chine allait revoir mais
j'ai tellement peur déçu tu vas mais à
l'époque c'était bien en indochine tueur
en trichant coiffeur way qui rentrait
chez elle pas faire autre coupé les
cheveux et en même temps il y avait un
petit bol qui te passe en dessous
si c'est là que eux ayité as tu sortais
du coiffeur on avait coupé les cheveux
tu étais rafraîchir tu avais je sais
l'invité c'était extraordinaire
l'état gunten bacon galliano me dit
mbaye l'hymne taïwanais comme diana min
mba dans le village de la cnam
j'avais une fumerie d'opium dagoudane
balkans galliano n'était pas le village
de luqman côté de fo
j'avais aidé ces petites fioles comme ça
enfin longer sur la nahd et on ouvrait
une petite pique d'opium une petite
boule blanche
lita gotye balcon garigliano victime va
y est petite boule blanche lincoln alors
à la norme kayhan avait dit mme a
c'est du rap c'est du rap indochinois
bien sûr mais c'est du rap quand même
avant alors j'ai vécu rade chine comme
ça bon et j'avais quand même c'est moi
c'est mon amour de 20 ans elle
s'appelait news yahoo
c'était mon amour de 20 ans c'était la
première fois que je faisais que
j'encule est que je me faisais sucer par
une paille petit indochinois tu vois
donc il y avait quand même un amour qu
est-ce qui s'étaient installés là et
quand j'ai quitté indochine 7 est grave
c'était une petite niakoués quelqu'un
qui était dans son cas quoi noir et
c'est sûr que je n'allais pas partir
comme ça à quitter le village vous avez
rencontré l ange une écoute ma chérie on
va aller à yvan et je vais te payer le
plus grand hôtel d'iphone qui se plaît
loot kite angle luca exemple est juste
en face la baie d'halong est alors on a
passé la petite n'a qu ai je vais payer
vraiment là est allé chez le coiffeur
elle est allée chez le coiffeur et
iphone et tout ça elle était belle
ravissante et ça et puis
il faut qu'on se quitte puisque le
bateau était là il va partir dans deux
heures et tout ça donc on s'embrasse
comme tel en ce pleurs dans les bras
je reviendrai vous mamie neu mme amina
une mine hoyle ça veut dire chéri à la
de chinois
mme amina et je reviendrai elles m'ont
binhai tu reviendras et tout ça bon et
je prends mon sac marin sur les pommes
et jeudi il faut pas que j'oublie bateau
et je bats je me barre vers le port
d'iphone pour prendre un bateau et
chantant derrière moi des petites
raquettes en bois tac tac tac tac tac la
claque
elle me poursuivait el maghra par la
chemise et je me dis [ __ ] je vais
quitter mon bateau c'est ce que j'ai
fait je me suis retournée dirige je me
suis retourné et j'ai foutu un grand
coup de prague et je les assume et j'ai
vu ces petites têtes en bois
l'agra gaulle est partout et tout ça
dure et ça y est j'ai pas rater mon
bateau
mais ce ne veut conserver un visage de
mon premier amour à moi je laissais
carré car à eau sur le port de hai phong
accepted cac est en bois
et
rien rater de winne a l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus